[Music]
some people think the top story today is
the president's trip to Europe and some
people think it's the crisis in Crimea
right now but judging by local news
there's an even bigger story out there
that's sweeping the nation check this
out sothanks new on Sunrise Frank Ocean
tells a major fast-food chain to buzz
off and which celeb peed in a glass jar
Frank Ocean tells a major fast food
chain to buzz off and which celeb peed
in a glass jar Frank Ocean tells a major
fast food chain to buzz off and which
celeb peed in a glass jar Frank Ocean
tells a major fast food chain to buzz
off in which celeb peed in a glass jar
interesting question a Frank Ocean
telling the major fast food chain to
buzz off and which celeb he's in a glass
jar Frank Ocean tells a major fast food
chain to buzz off and which celeb peed
in a glass jar Frank Ocean tells a major
fast food chain to buzz off and which
celeb peed in a glass jar Frank Ocean
tells a major fast food chain to buzz
off and which celeb actually peed in a
glass jar Frank Ocean tells a major fast
food chain to buzzed off also an
interesting story here what celebrity
would pee in a glass jar Frank Ocean
telling a major fast food chain to
buzzed off and which celebrity did
something in a glass jar Frank Ocean
tells a major fast food chain to buzz
off and which celeb used the potty and a
glass jar Frank Ocean
a major fast-food chain to buzz off and
which celeb used a glass jar for the
restroom Frank Ocean a major fast-food
chain to buzz off and which celebrity
used the restroom in a glass jar let's
say that Frank Ocean tells a major
fast-food chain to buzz off and which
celeb used a glass jars a restroom mmm
[Applause]